we're not buying your good girl act
Audrey sure Malin Ben finally apologized
to you and Mouse dad saved your life but
none of that would have been necessary
if the V case had never come to Oregon
you're new here aren't you I'm Audrey
princess Audrey acting nice isn't your
strong suit and that's okay you're the
queen of me not the princess of niceness
seeing you with a big smile on your face
as mal became the queen of the aisle and
auradon was super strange and out of
character so tell us Audrey are you
really over it
we love descendants three but some of
the things that went down in the three
quill just don't add up keep watching to
find out why it wasn't game over after
the ember got wet now gets engaged at 17
Disney has made it clear that their
princesses don't need to get married at
the end of their stories anymore many of
us would consider mal a new-age princess
but for some strange reason her
character has some very backward views
were we the only ones who found it
strange that mal agreed to get married
to Ben when she was only 17 years old
probably not getting married is a huge
deal and becoming the queen of both
auradon and the Isle is an even bigger
deal sure mal and then love each other
and are perfect for their roles but
they're like super young then and mal
were both 16 years old when they first
met and no more than one year later they
got engaged to be married we can't help
but wonder if mal was interested in
traveling the world or studying abroad
she seems a little too young to be
cemented into a lifelong role while we
love the idea of Malin been getting
married we think it happened way too
fast we owe you an apology at the end of
descendants three moments after Hades
uses his ember to save Audrey something
very bizarre happens
Audrey apologizes to everyone for
wanting to hurt them I'm sorry I want to
hurt you both and then mal tells Audrey
that she's owed her an apology for a
very long time
Ben chimes in and grandma Leah does too
but did anyone notice that Audrey is the
old
one who actually said I'm sorry now Ben
and Leah only admitted to owning
apologies but what's even stranger is
that that never took the time to
properly end his long-term relationship
with Audrey then is a stand-up guy who
can't wait to change the world he's
brave and outspoken but when it comes to
Audrey he's none of these things
Malon Ben fell in love very quickly in
the first Descendants film but then
never once thought to break up with
Audrey after humiliating her at the
tourney game he chose to avoid her
instead and then he proposed to mal in
front of everyone without breaking the
news to Audrey first at this point
Audrey still believe that she could win
Ben back so a heads-up would have been
nice is it just us or is Ben the villain
of Audrey's story the Isles rightful
ruler
Malin uma used to be best friends but
then they became enemies now always had
the upper hand and constantly viewed uma
as her number two but uma is a leader in
her own right when she found out that
mal had lied to her about letting the
kids off the isle she ditched mal in a
hurry but she soon came back to help mal
save Celia without Emma and her Pirate's
mal would have never been able to defeat
Audrey so what does mal do to repair she
takes over the Isle we were convinced
that uma would become the queen of the
Isle
after all she chose to forego her
freedom to help the BK's have a better
life she was ready to never step foot in
auradon again for the sake of her people
uma would have made a wonderful Queen
she was even decked out in a brand new
dress when mal took down the barrier and
claimed the isle for herself we would
have loved to see uma and mal rise to
the top together leave an octopus emoji
in the comments if you feel the same or
don police force using magic has been
frowned down upon ever since fairy
godmother locked the villains up on the
Isle of the laws the vast majority of
magical items were donated to the museum
so it's safe to assume that the Oregon
police used combat and weaponry to stop
potential threads and not magic which
can cause problems in the future if
there's one thing that didn't make sense
in this
and three it's how mal took down the
barrier without a moment's notice once
the barrier came down hundreds of angry
and poor magical people were unleashed
which isn't exactly safe sure most of
them aren't evil but a lot of them are
it would have been a good idea for the
police in auradon to learn how to use
magic first this way if anyone tried to
take over auradon like audrey just did
there would be protocols in place and
skilled heroes who know how to beat
villains at their own game
some extra preparation wouldn't have
hurt and it would have made the merge a
whole lot safer King Ben then has all
the makings of a wonderful King he's
brave kind and wants to make the world a
better place for everyone villains
included but then was only sixteen years
old when he was crowned king which is a
little strange since he was still a
student at auradon prep Elsa didn't
become the official queen of arendelle
until she was 21 years old and that's
quite an age gap beast and Belle could
have continued rolling over at word on
until Ben was of legal age putting a
kingdom in the hands of a teenager isn't
the best idea
but luckily then was very mature for his
age if Beast and Belle had continued
drooling over auradon the barrier never
would have come down and the core four
would have still been locked up on the
Isle so while we're happy then became a
king at 16 years old we're still a
little puzzled by it barrier breach just
a wave of my stick fairy godmother has
got to be one of the most powerful
Disney characters of all time we mean
she can resurrect people for crying out
loud she brought all the villains back
to life and imprisoned them on the Isle
of the Lost
but for some strange reason barrier
breaches happen every single time the
barrier gets taken down in descendants
three now suggested they permanently
closed the barrier to prevent villains
from escaping these fell and now truly
believe that this was the only way to
keep auradon safe but couldn't bury
godmother have used her wand to prevent
villains from slipping past the barrier
instead of
taking the barrier down to let people
through fairy godmother could have used
her wand to let specific people through
this way no one but the chosen vks would
be able to enter auradon considering the
extent of fairy godmothers powers this
solution should have been obvious from
the get-go the Ember the question on
everyone's mind is why was mal able to
use the amber after Celia threw it into
the well well we're still waiting for an
answer when Hades agreed to give mal his
ember he told her that she couldn't use
it to its maximum potential because she
was only a demigod he also told her that
if she got it wet it would be game over
so when Celia found out that mal wanted
to close the barrier down for good she
threw the Ember into a well mal tried
everything to revive the Ember but not
even dragon fire could ignite the blue
gem so why is it that Ouma and mouse
combined magics were able to do the
impossible and on a side note why didn't
the Ember get wet when uma caught it
while in the octopus form her tentacles
were dripping with water as it turns out
wetting the amber wasn't game over so
does that mean that Hades lied or is
something else afoot here
why do you think uma and mal were able
to revive the Ember sound off in the
comments dizzy and the Smee twins
there's no doubt about it
dizzy Tremaine is one of the best
characters in The Descendants franchise
she's funky peppy and super talented and
in the months leading up to the
descendents three premiere tizzy
appeared in a bunch of trailers so fans
were under the impression that she'd
have a bigger role in d3 than she did in
d2 but that wasn't exactly the case and
the same goes for the Smee twins
Celia dizzy squeaky and squirmy were
chosen to attend auradon prep Disney's
descendants release tons of fun trailers
in their honor
but when it came time for them to shine
they were nowhere to be found
dizzy in the Smee twins spent most of
the three pool sleeping which was a
total bummer we would have loved to see
more from these characters and we aren't
the only ones some fans even went as far
as to say that the Smee twins shouldn't
have been include
in the movie at all the people are in a
panic ever since uma managed to slither
through the barrier the people of
auradon have been in a state of total
panic so in the Queen's crown and
Maleficent sceptre were stolen from the
museum the people of auradon were
absolutely terrified the thought of an
evil villain on the loose was enough for
them to board up their doors and windows
but at the end of descendants three
everyone agreed that taking down the
entire barrier all at once was a great
decision people chose to have faith in
the villains and no one panics as
hundreds of poorly treated angry
villains walked into auradon now speech
was beautiful and true but not everyone
in auradon was there to hear it so we
can just imagine how many people
panicked and fled their homes when they
found out that the entire barrier was
down for good princess of niceness
[Applause]
you'd really rather have a PT on the
throne than me let's get one thing out
of the way
Audrey has never been a nice girl dak
was born and raised to be the best and
to value status above all else we know
that Audrey didn't actually mean to hurt
anyone in auradon
that was the scepters evildoing but
Audrey started singing her queen of mean
song before ever laying a finger on the
sceptre she broke into the museum and
stole the crown before going on a
rampage but after being defeated by mal
and cured by Hades Audrey acted like it
wasn't her fault even though she'd had
bad intentions from the beginning Audrey
may have been embarrassed and apologetic
but that doesn't mean that she's given
up on becoming Queen and we're not
buying her good girl Act Audrey may be
laying low for now but we doubt she'll
let then Mary Mel without making a scene
or two while we absolutely love to send
in three some of its scenes have still
got us talking what are some of your
favorite scenes from the three quom
sound off in the comments and that's a
wrap subscribe to the things and don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up thanks for watching we'll see you
next time
you